my name is rel himself for coming and
thanks for inviting me I'm honored to be
speaking here at my data
after several meet ups in which I was in
the attendance and not in this side of
the stage a bit about me as probably my
accent already sold me I'm from
Argentina
I lived several years in Uruguay I know
that here there is some your why on
people so I got to say that and eight
years ago I came to Israel I studied in
the Hebrew University of Jerusalem then
in Tel Aviv University yeah everyone's
topic I also did one course in the
Technium so now I work as a data
scientist and on forest I will tell a
later of it out on forest but during my
work there I got exposed to a type of
models in machine learning which are
probably not very popular but are really
useful and with a lot of applications
that they are called learning to rank so
just to be sure and who's here work
frequently with learning to rent models
okay there are a few how many of you
heard about learning to rank okay a few
more that's great yeah but yeah before I
started working in and run forest I've
never heard about learning to rank so
this was very interesting for me and I
want to share with you some of the
things that I learned in the last year
okay so first of all what is learning to
rank very simple it's the usage of
machine learning to build ranking
systems and where can we find them and
well in search engines that's probably
the most famous application of learning
to run also in e-commerce website
Hotels search engines and streaming
services there are some more
applications but probably this those are
the most famous ones and all of them use
some form of learning to rank sorry so
what's the use case in run forest run
forest it's a company that tries to
empower consumers by simplifying the
research and giving them the possibility
to to make more informed shopping
decisions how do we do that we have some
we have some websites that show the best
deals available and do some a product
comparison and we get our product
database from several retailers online
yeah also the largest one but also some
small retailers why why learning to run
for us it's important because obviously
when we are doing both like when we are
showing deals or when we are doing
product comparison in everything that we
show to the user we want to show them
the most relevant or better products on
the top of the words website and the
less relevant we want to put them on the
bottom or not show them at all
and the first question is what is why is
it different from regular classification
or regression in machine learning
that's a question I made to myself what
why is it different and it's actually
not very different if we if we think of
for example the problem of just
classifying a relevant item from a not
relevant item relevant item I could be
using a classification algorithm and if
I'm just ordering things according to
some ordinal score for example ratings
from 1 to 5 or writing from 0 to 10 and
just those are the big typical numbers
then I could use regression to predict
this score and then other products or
items in our case its product
by this car and this is called point
wise learning to rank but what if
instead of doing that we can actually
for for the same query we can compare
during the training the different
products that we have available and then
we can do it this pairwise so we will
take each pair of items documents or
products and compare against each other
and decide which one is the better the
best one and the second option is just
take the full list and try to do some
optimization about it so we could use
regression classification for learning
to run problems but that's not the
optimal way to do it and the comparison
during training of different documents
it were actually makes it different and
then now that we know what is different
on what is the the meaning of doing
learning to rank the first thing that
the first thing that we can ask yourself
if okay we'll train a model and based on
what I'm going to optimize it and those
are some of the most common common
metrics but I will focus only on and ECG
normalize discount cumulative again
because that's the metric that we use at
run Forrest so what is this metric it's
a sort of relevance call for the full
list so what we see here it's that first
we can for every ranking that we have we
can compute the DCT discounted
cumulative gain which is basically the
sum of the of the relevant scores of all
the items until some position P and they
are weighted by the post their
deposition in which they are shown and
because usually we are most interested
in the first positions than in the last
ones so we make some discount over the
positions and finally we compare the
to the ideal DCG and we get our metric
one of the good things about doing this
is that it's very simple to a transition
from a regular classification or
regression problem to learning to rank
and in our case we use the boosting
algorithms and all of the main libraries
for boosting have the possibility to
work with lambda rank which is a way of
optimizing ranking systems in our case
now we are using a light GBM and it's
very simple to do it we just have to say
that the objective its lambda rank we
have to say that the metric that we are
optimizing it's and ECG the position in
which we are optimizing it that in our
case it's the position number 10 so we
are only taking into account for the
optimization the first time the first n
items and the last Queen it's that we
have to sort our input according to the
unit to the query I did so in our data
set we have product products that
correspond to a particular user query
and we ordered them by their query and
we say to the algorithm that which are
the lengths of each query so if in my
g-train which relates to the group I
will have in the in the first position
let's say five that we mean to the first
five products correspond to the first
query we have a set of features we want
from those features to get an output and
if if I see if I see this as my x and y
for the first question another question
is which is my work which is my Y and
where can I get it from and essentially
I have two possibilities
the first one it's get some explicit
feedback that will mean that I will
how some judges probably we hire them to
go over a few queries not a few actually
a lot and say what is relevant what is
not for give a score but this usually
it's very expensive I cannot get very
big data set and I cannot always trust
the judges and they also don't represent
the common user because the judges that
I'm hire that I'm hiring it's they are
not necessarily think like the users
that actually come to my website so the
alternative is to have some implicit
feedback that will mean that I will use
the engagement of real users as a metric
of relevance and using this I can get a
lot of data it is a way it represents
wealthy the average CEO so that the talk
that comes to my site but the website
it's that usually this data maybe it's
not of a higher quality it's a bit
ambiguous it's noisy and as we will
discuss now it's also biased so what are
the challenges here the first one it's a
position bias this bias it's usually
very nature natural when when I show the
user the when I show the use of the
different items in a in a query
I already I'm showing I'm showing him
this results by a certain ranking or
certain order and disorder affects the
engagement and after I have this
engagement I'm going to use this in the
training data and here we have the bias
so how can we solve or at least reduce
device here the first one it's just use
random samples instead of using instead
of using samples based on some ranking
that I did in the past I'm just showing
for a small percentage of users
completely random
results and using this for training
purposes the problem is that if I have
yeah everyone that I want to expand over
the time even having one percent of the
users having random results it's very
well for the business the second one is
that I can do it filter and seen result
unseen I mean things that I'm I'm not
sure that the user has examined so I'm
only considering for example if I have a
problem in which I looking at what was
clicked and what was not I will probably
take things that are above the last
click and the research paper that I
mentioned here suggests that we can do
that we can estimate the actual position
by us by do by using a expectation
maximization maximization algorithm and
they will things that we can also use
the same feature set of our length rank
model and then after that I estimated
the bias of the position I can use the
inverse of it and as sample weights so
this way the d for example the clicks
that i'm getting in lower in lower
positions will get stronger weight than
things that clicks that i get in the
first positions and the last option at
least options that we use in run Forrest
it's something suggested by Google
Google's rules of machine learning that
says that we can use the position as a
feature of the model and then when we
are in production we can use the same
constant position to predict or use also
or limit us and I but this has a small
problem that sometimes it's not
consistent the ranking that I get by
select by predicting everything from
position one sometimes it's not the same
that when I leave is leave it as and I
a second challenge that we have been
learning to rank it's context awareness
if I use features that are only
dependent on on the document for example
in run folders in run forest we have the
price of a product if I use only the
price as a feature then I then like I'm
not sure okay I have this price that
could be $40 but it's $40 when the all
the products are around the $100 or this
is $40 when all the products are around
40 or 45 dollars that changes a lot and
the first recommendation it's to use
also features that are relative to all
the other documents in the query and the
second suggestion suggestion also by a
research paper that says that we can of
course use deep learning because
nowadays we have to use deep learning
for something we can create the context
by some representation of a neural net
the two possibilities that they suggest
is first evaluating each product against
each other and aggregate the results on
a matrix and then use a convolutional
neural network to to move from to
transition from this matrix to final
scores and the second solution that they
say it's that we can first aggregate all
the products in a in a context vector it
will be a sort of embedding and then use
this embedding as extra features and for
the model and that get the scores and
the last challenge it's a lack of
diversity and I think this is the main
problem of learning to rank algorithms
it's that we were learning to rank
algorithms I'll build two just to score
to score the items according to the
relevancy but for example if the user is
searching best mobile phones
and the most relevant result could be
iPhone x6 right and the second one will
be iPhone 9 and the third one will be
iPhone 8 because they are one of the
best mobile phone so it's logical that
that's the model will say but the user
don't want to see if he's generally
searching mobile phones he don't want to
see he doesn't want to say all iPhones
so we also have to solve this problem
how can we solve it we can create a
similarity matrix of the different
documents that we have and use the
elements of this matrix as a
regularization parameters to penalize
similar items in closed results the
second one is to some sort of real
ranking first we rank and like we of the
original ranking we ranked according to
relevance and then we try to rank to do
a new ranking that tries to optimize
diversity subject to that the original
ranking it's not affected too much and
the first solution which is what I
prefer it's doing some greedy
optimization I have my icon my original
ranking and I only add items that do not
decrease the type the general diversity
of the full list so I think that I spoke
a bit too fast but I'm done so questions
see envision when they value the image
at once stuff like that they do need
some kind of the many the top five uses
of them accusing but the model was
really trained Frank just takes on the
subject
after all the table so how do you
actually train at work right okay so
first of all I'm not an expert on this
side of the optimization I'm in more
data person but as far as I'm concerned
the the usual methods take each pair of
items that that I have on the same query
and it's a sort of classification in
which I say is this item better than the
second one
so they transform the observations to
pair of two pair of observations and do
some sort of classification and the
difference with the lambda rank it's
that they don't need the actual the
actual classification but they only need
the gradient of this classification but
I'm not an expert that's what I think
the positive versus the negative also
inside the positive you make some legs
because I don't anymore
so suppose that i have i'm i'm now
classifying
which I am classifying a particular pair
of items and there are two possibilities
one is better than the other one right
or they are the same according to my
score so basically that's suppose I'm
just classifying is item one better than
item two is item two better than item
one or they are the same that they don't
sit yeah what the that question it's not
it doesn't matter if it's implicit or
explicit in implicit means that for
example I could use if a user clicked or
not on a
product if the user ordered a product or
not so in our case for example we use
like zero says that the product wasn't
clicked one means that the product was
click and two means that the product was
ordered so if so two beats 1 1 bits 0
and we do the classification based on
that ok so she's asking how do I deal
with two different users that for the
same query and ranked things differently
the one clicked on something and the
other click on something else and this
usually it's embedded in the context the
context not in all cases but in most
cases explains well which user I'm
dealing with so I have features that
represent also the user for example I
don't know demographics or a
technological details that I have on the
user ok thank you very much
[Applause]